now clashers have broken out in paris
between police and
protesters demonstrating against what
they say
are worsening employment conditions and
deteriorating social rights and freedoms
in france the protest comes as president
emmanuel macron's government
faces heavy criticism trying to push
through a new security law
it says is intended to protect police
officers
and a crackdown on islamist groups
police use
tear gas to deter the protesters as they
made their way to the city's
place de la republique
for more on this let's bring in dw's
lisa lewis
in the northeastern section of paris
lisa we've seen
images of smoke and perhaps even some
flames at times
what exactly is going on
well there have been thousands of people
protesting here today
in paris in and in about 80 other cities
across france they have been creating
protesting for more social rights as you
said but also against
a new security bill and there have been
clashes right
from the beginning of the demonstrations
based
on here in paris uh protesters who've
actually um who've been trained things
that the police and the police have
retaliated with tear gas a window
as of shops have been smashed and these
clashes are still ongoing here in paris
french president emmanuel macron as you
no doubt are aware has been
out defending the new security law even
as the government has backtracked on
some parts of it why do they insist on
keeping the law in place
well it's very important for the
government to show that they're trying
everything they can
to keep the french safe they're also
bending in from pressure
to pressure from the police here in
france who is
asking who are asking for more
protection actually from attacks against
them
the attacks against police have risen
over the past few years and the
government is responding to that
but it is a fine line because on the one
hand the government wants to show that
it understands police
the police but they also want to show
that they understand the people and
the backlash against this new security
bill in particular is rising
you know as we see images of some of the
people there on the streets are next to
you to curse me that segments of french
society
have always felt empowered to express
their freedom of speech
what's your sense of this do the voices
on the streets today represent a small
piece of the population
or is there in fact a rising groundswell
there in france
well according to recent polls half of
the french
really support those who are opposing
the bill
at the same time there are also lots of
people who
are afraid for their safety as you know
there have been numerous terror attacks
over the past two weeks and months here
in france that have added to a series of
terror attacks over the past few years
and the french know that they need to be
protected
so it is very difficult for the
government what's more
president macron he wants to prepare the
ground for 2022
when the next presidential elections
will happen and he's trying to
appeal to right-wing voters especially
with this new security bill but also
with other bills
that he's putting at the total trade on
the table at the moment
so it is difficult for the government to
find a balance between
enough security but not too much
lisa lewis in paris as always lisa many
many thanks